la présence du chef de cabinet ou de son
adjoint à proximité du président de la
république n'était pas systématique
elles étaient systématiques sur les
déplacements du président de la
république mais pas systématique dont
son environnement le plus proche
il accompagnait le président la
république pour faire face à tout
événement du type organisationnel en
lien avec le préfet territorialement
compétent encore une fois ou avec
l'ambassadeur de france ou avec les
autorités étrangères qui nous
accueillait mais sa présence n'était pas
toujours immédiatement à côté du
président la république ça clairement
c'est un choix du président de la
république lui-même
c'est lui qui définit qui souhaite avoir
à ses côtés c'est si tu sais quelque
chose qui est propre à chaque président
il ne faut pas oublier que la sécurité
du président république c'est avant tout
un lien de confiance qui doit
s'installer et que les règles sans être
transgressée s'adapte à la personnalité
du président mais encore une fois je
tiens beaucoup à ce lien de confiance
parce que la sécurité rapprochée c'est
quelque chose d'impalpable c'est c'est
fait ou ce n'est pas fait c'est bien
assuré c'est bien prévu où ça ne l'est
pas c'est souvent difficile à percevoir
et je crois que la plus grande réussite
pour un chef de la sécurité du président
la république c'est que le président de
la république ne pense pas sa sécurité